apply
i have to say i'm worried a little bit
by the term template reaction because
i don't know we've got lots of other
templates running around but let's let's
see how it works
chemical reaction template chemical
reaction
i mean it's really okay let's see how it
works
okay
so
okay so this is some kind of smart
string that represents that reaction
which we are representing like this
and our
full form for this is
molecule pattern
so what does molecule pattern mean where
is the pattern part of molecule pattern
right uh so
it looks for it so it's a substructure
pattern it like so it describes a sub
graph a substructure in the molecule so
this one it would be just a c-o-o
with a double bond in there and so it
[Music]
yeah so this is a piece of graph
rewriting basically do we have any of
the people here who know about graph
rewriting who've worked on graph
rewriting
i
have not with our code though i don't
know the details under the hood for
graph but i've done graph rewriting
no i understand but people i mean the
physics project is full of graph
rewriting oh we don't have anyone here
okay so we need somebody from that um
i don't know if
uh
i don't know if nick will be available
or james
but jason you're discussing this with
people right
but there's two different graph groups
there's there's the graph theory group
and charles poo that's one group and
then there's the people who worked on
the physics project where we have a
boatload of wfr functions which are
slowly getting worked towards
finalization okay uh nick merzin will be
the most relevant person i don't know if
he's awake
around at this time maybe cory could go
and check that please
i just
okay if he happens to be available it'd
be great if he joined
okay so the problem here is that you've
got a completely new and different way
of representing pattern variables here
than any other part of the system
right
okay so that's not going to work
period end of story i can tell you right
now it's not going to work
i think the use of the word better
barrier is a little bit misleading
because
it isn't really a person variable in
some sense i would argue
it's a pattern atom
no i mean i'm what you're saying is
if there's a molecule it has a little
piece that looks like this
um
then um
okay let's try to understand what this
is
so this means
oh nick is here great
um
okay can you explain to me what this can
you show me an example
where
i mean this is simply the template can
you show me the template in use
open the esterification section please
first uh the intermolecular one there
the first example down a little bit is
acetic acid plus ethanol
and in the box shows it all drawn out
okay so hold on so this is saying
i don't really understand what's
happening here so so the question of
indicating where the pattern varia i
mean so
we start with this molecule yes
right that's acetic acid and that
matches the first no no i think that's
not i think that knowledge steve means
with the question
we we have this abstract representation
that says as long as you have something
that has this and something that has
this then we can do this and then there
is a position of different things we can
apply it
yeah it's just like the physics project
it's just like what we have to do there
right so we've got this
thing where there are two oxygens one of
them is connected with a double bond
right
right
and so what that means is this thing
here
that piece there
matches that right
yes
and it's and there's one possible match
in this particular case
correct
and in principle
there could be two matches on this
molecule for that graph fragment right
yes that would be the second example
the
did you put in a multiple
fan the other one is with the multiple
matrix with the
right i mean there will be there will be
multiple match examples but uh just i
mean just focus on the on the one yeah
okay so this is
really really really directly analogous
to what we're doing with the physics
project
so now the issue is always
okay so the question is how do you
re-glue pieces of the graph
do you understand the question yeah
so we have that piece of the graph
we're taking that out
and
how do we re-glue it
so the numbering on the left-hand side
and numbering on the right-hand side
which says how do you have to re-glue
right and so any any any part of the
your input molecule that wasn't matched
by the pattern but is bonded to one of
the atoms in the pattern
will
that bond and and all the atoms attached
to it are brought over to the products
the addressing on the re-gluing the
rewriting is handled through the atom
map numbers
there they are the uh atom map number
options in the wolfram language form and
it's the
digit or the integer that follows the
colon in the
reaction smarts and there's a generally
one-to-one from left to right
okay so
turning on nick here
do you see
okay so like if we have like wolf model
type things
where we've got
we've got named
atoms of space in that particular
case which don't have an eye okay so the
the difference with what we have in
hypergraph rewriting
is
we don't have a tag like this is a
carbon atom
we just have the name of that atom of
space
and we don't have a notion of like
double bonds and so on
but otherwise i think it's the same
or am i missing something it is it is
the same that that example that i did
using graph and rewriting stuff
but not able to use um
uh attributes um annotations
in graphs
uh you know it basically demonstrated
that i i managed the annotations on my
own
to do the matching
okay but but
okay
so wait a second so we've got three
different projects that are all doing
something very similar
we've got
the whole wolf and model hypograph
rewriting
stuff
we've got a potential project
in the graph theory area doing generic
graph rewriting and we've got this
project is that correct
as far as i know yeah
and what about the trees people do they
have yet another project doing tree
replacements
i'm not aware of anything there but you
know
they could i don't know i think i think
there is stuff there
sorry nick did you have any comments
about this and how it relates to the
graph rewriting we've done
look looks very similar
it's like it can be
i think like all of this writing uh
can be just expression writing
with some
i don't know
i think all of this can be just a
complicated
tuple replacement subset replacement
thing
so i should just say
yeah
but so the issue here is
the awkward thing
okay i actually got another chemistry
question
are these arrows always one way
for this uh
for this data structure yes
i mean in a real reaction i mean uh you
would have that reaction and its reverse
existing in equilibrium
oftentimes
but the equilibrium could be very much
to one side but the way the way that
these uh um
template reactions are are set up and
i'm open for a different name but uh
um
but just
the patterns on the left can be very um
open-ended that you can say that the
atom number three can be a chlorine it
can be a carbon it can be a bromine
but
that kind of thing would not be present
on the right-hand side it on the right
hand side you say that that atom is what
is whatever it was right it's like
saying it's exactly analogous to saying
on the left
to saying something like you know you've
got a pattern of the form x colon
and then it's you know carbon or
fluorine or whatever right yes and then
and then but on the right
now
that goes to some f of x
right
right yes
okay
now
yeah so i mean
you know the thing that would to me be
seem much better
okay the molecule pattern construct do
we already have that or not
yes
and what does it do
so uh let's see i mean you can use it in
a molecule plot to highlight a
substructure
it can be fed to a fine molecule
substructure or
or test or there's tests for its
presence
okay but
so what it what it does right now it
doesn't have name variables correct
correct
okay so what does it represent so it
represents a subpart of a molecule right
now
without any names yes
okay so the subparting of a molecule
okay for a molecule right now the only
way you can identify the subpart
is through essentially it's it's it's
tagged graph structure and by tagged
graph structure i mean
you know it's got names for the it's got
types for the atoms
correct and it's got types for the bonds
as well what happens if there's
stereochemistry
so uh that gets lumped into an option in
a molecule um it will be added to
molecule pattern um but we don't have a
pattern for that at the moment
so fundamentally the stereochemistry so
what we've got here
the molecule pattern on the left is
identical to the one on the right in the
sense that it is we can think of it as
just a sub graph
with named tags and so on
but then the new thing on the left is
we've got to
have
we've got to name parts of the pattern
that we are matching
to be used on the right hand side
correct
and i don't understand why we're not
just using a mechanism
that is
why don't we just use the pattern
matcher i mean why don't we just say
here
okay to rewrite this okay let me let me
rewrite this
and i understand there's one issue here
but i'm going to rewrite this anyway
okay so let's say we forget this
okay
and we're just basically saying x colon
this
forget that
it's y colon this
and then we go on the right hand side
arrow
and there's no atom c anything it's just
x
if that's what you want it to be you get
what i'm saying
uh pretty much uh sometimes the formal
charge on an atom may change uh or it
might uh end up being a radical and have
an unpaired electron
okay so we we have to account for that
as well
this is where the stereochemistry could
come in also
okay but fundamentally the
in our language
the representation
of
i mean we also have to think about when
we do a graph pattern
um
and we want to go back and forth between
smart and if smarts have the number
labeling we must somehow preserve them
right and also i mean so we we
definitely were thinking about this
about these lines i mean so
so a i mean
we could write them as patterns like
this and i would uh i mean
we do not use the pattern matcher to
find uh substructures inside a molecule
so
so it would have to be parsed and uh
and um yeah i understand
but uh
one of the things that really struck me
is say we are uh generating uh reactions
from a list of uh these uh smarts type
reactions
how do we come up with the x the why um
yeah i know i know so that was the last
thought right so probably what we would
have to do
is use some
you know
i'm not sure i mean we could use a
letter like character followed by a
number
i mean that would be one way to do it
i'm not sure i like that
but that would be one way to do it i
mean like like for example let's say
um i think there would be no because
unavoidable it would live in global
which is
off-limits
i should just say
well
uh
i agree the atom mapping numbers do seem
very counter-intuitive especially when
you see them written out like that uh in
the end i feel like this thing is going
it's it's going to come into its own
when we're able to draw these or to take
an actual
fully fledged chemical reaction and
create a template reaction by chopping
off bits and
designing uh
let's ask this question i don't know the
answer to this
if we
um this object pattern
does it allow us to have what does it
what does it say about its first
argument
so it says its name must be a symbol
i wonder whether the parser thinks that
yes i think so
well it certainly does in the case where
it's x blank
i don't think you can make a compound it
will not work properly
what do you mean so you mean if i say if
i say one column
no but if i say this something like this
um
[Music]
i wonder if that works if i say that
if i say f of that
well this is probably going to be very
unhappy
i can't imagine that's going to work and
now i say
f of
okay
okay
um okay so let's let's go back here
all right let me just think for a second
so
when we think about graph rewriting
for example in
let me let me show
this example
um
ah where is it
um there we go
okay
so this is a typical
piece of graph rewriting
i don't know what that
oh there we go yes
so i mean this is hypograph rewriting
okay so this these are names of atoms
these are these are pattern names for
atoms which we have sloppily not had as
x blank i think we have a version of
this where we do include the x blank
nick can you comment on that
oh yeah there's some function that
converts rules back and forth like
pattern rules something like that
right
but so let me just compare and contrast
this kind of rewriting with what we're
doing over here
okay so here we have names for the atoms
but no tags for the atoms
am i making sense
pegs being the other properties of the
atom
well things like it's the fact that it's
oxygen yeah okay
okay in addition
in this case we have well we have
i mean this happens to be just a graph
which is what you have here and you also
have tags for the edges here that is the
double bonds for example
yep
okay
yeah i i tried to write reactions with
these uh hypergraph rewrite rules two
years ago and it just did not work
okay we're trying to to reproduce some
some chemical reactions with it
and the best i could do is to use
multiple edges between atoms to
represent multiple bonds but everything
had to be carbon because i couldn't do
anything else in terms of
annotations
nick can you comment from your more
general functions
that we used for example in the matter
mathematics project
do we have ways to effectively have more
annotation
of these atoms
well i had a version that works for
general expression so
and i can
like for for example much replace
function that i had
okay is that in the function repository
yet yeah
i'm like in the process of revising it
but the old version is there
and
it
this function has an ability to
have a left hand side that acts on a
three
separated expressions
right
so it has if it's a list
if the left-hand side of your rule is a
list then it searches for both of them
and it can map at multiple positions at
once and then it's just a matter of
how you splice it back
and for at least i have like a special
rule that it actually uses place
so we can
somehow create a rule that acts exactly
like hypergraph
a placement but i see general expression
maybe we should maybe you should explain
it we should go through this in more
detail because i think this seems highly
relevant
do you believe that you could write with
multi-replace you could actually write
this template template
the reaction apply function does it seem
that you couldn't well i think so yeah i
don't see an immediate problem with that
okay maybe there's a glacier there but
not sure
but so
in that case how would you represent
the templates
oh it's if it's a graph
on the left hand side and the on the
right hand side
right but the problem is the naming of
the nodes
yeah the problem is the naming of the
nodes
well
you can just have an
like
uh some any
expression that has a name in it
and you just have a pattern that matches
against this name
can we do it more explicitly could you
give a suggestion for what this would
actually look like so in this case we've
got
well okay
guys
and your expression is a list of like
expressions the x y x y
in this case it would be a list of
bonds
and your left hand side would also
expect some
like just edges
minion vertex goes to vertex
and you can replace it with new vertices
okay but let's be explicit go ahead
uh one difference with for example used
in the esterification reaction
uh where we were looking at so you have
two oxygen two oxygen so they're both
oxygen but they are connected
differently to the carbon in the
carboxylic acid component how are you
supposed to
do that with the multiverse
what what are you pointing to yon
the for the esterification reaction go
to the one the one at the very top
of what you're looking at now
here
a little that one yes that one so for
the first pattern or carboxylic acid
pattern you have two oxygens
connected to a carbon but they are
connected in different ways
so i mean you up
your vertices with the same label but
for lack of a better than different
environments so how are you supposed to
do that with the replace
[Music]
well i mean this here
that's cute you can get it to light up
like that
that's that's right i i so i'm glad
you're like i haven't sent that to
design yet but uh
yeah
it makes one wonder whether we should
have that happen for patterns in general
wow interesting idea that if you just
have a pattern
you know that that's a suggestion for
user assistance
it would be nice to be able to visualize
complicated patterns very
sorry to visualize general patterns like
alphabet yes general but yes general
practice not just this one yeah right
okay but anyway so what you're saying is
let's take a look at this this is
this is so unbelievably similar to a
token event graph situation where you've
got
this piece
and this piece
okay nick do you understand what this is
doing
do you understand the chemistry i mean
what
let's take an example of where this is
used okay
so we've got
where where the heck is the molecule
okay
so in this case
this pattern
matches one molecule this pattern
matches on a different molecule right
these can't both measure the same
molecule correct the way this is written
that's true
yes
so that's kind of the metal logic
of the chemistry
is that that has to be those have to be
on different atoms is that generally
true of all no no it's not general
and we have examples further on this
notebook where we show that
you can do it either way
and you can make it expressly one way or
the other okay so i'm a little bit
confused about the physics of this okay
so we've got two molecules bouncing
around
and they're going to crash into each
other and there's some exchange of of
bonds and so on but how can that happen
there's no if it's a if it's a
self-reaction so to speak that can't
happen right but it's to be long enough
all right
and that really happens
yes yes
the reactions are actually more likely
to happen than the intermolecular ones
yeah
because the thing because the flux of i
mean because the the things are
guaranteed to be right there
okay so what's that what's a famous
example you see i've been like i've been
reading teo's book about chemical
reactions i haven't got to one like that
yet what's a famous example of a of a
snake biting its tail type reaction this
one this one too there's an
intramolecular version of esterification
much further included
yeah it's further down i don't know of a
famous one
but
it
does biology use molecules biting their
tails a lot
it happens yes
[Music]
what is it
speaking of rather large ones right so
we we have circles we represent circular
uh peptides and dna and everything else
right they're quite common and it's made
linearly and then the ends are stitched
together that's what you say yeah well
that with that one i've certainly heard
of
but those are okay
the lactonization is the intramolecular
version of what's happening
sorry i wanted to say that we need a way
to visualize the fact that in that
template reaction um
those two pieces are
listed as disconnected parts of the same
graph on the left hand side like the
same molecule as opposed to the plus
thing exactly right
yeah i guess the lack of a plus is the
uh
although i think in the end a frame
around them might be good okay but in
the smarts version how is it represented
that's a plus and the other one isn't
uh with parentheses well the dot for the
two disconnected parts but parentheses
around the whole thing
says that it's an intramolecular uh no
parentheses says it's intermolecular
and parentheses around the part to the
left of the dot and parentheses around
the part to the right of the dot also
means that it's inter-molecular
okay i'm just trying to emphasize tur
and trough
um yeah
[Music]
okay
all right
so
interpret this
nick can do you have an interpretation
of this
gosh what the hell is going on here in
the
intramolecular case
so
in a token event graph
these are just two tokens
no i'm confused here
in in the token event graphs those would
if for the intermolecular case they
would be two tokens in an intramolecular
case
uh the rewriting would be done on a
single token with one by one of the
rules
but i thought that they
see the thing that i'm confused about
each one of these pieces is a token
i think
like in this case yes no i understand
but in the other case
those two pieces
the head and the tail can be anywhere on
the molecule
correct
so i don't understand
i mean
okay okay
you know
in the physics case
this is like the standard case there are
two pieces of the universe
where the universe is a molecule
and they are
combined in some way
okay
and and what this is doing is it's
saying they combine in some way but then
you break off a new universe
that is quite separate
so i mean in other words
in
look in next case here we've got a
single expression that is being
multi-replaced by a rule
it seems like this is a case where
and that's the case here a single
expression where there's a rule being
applied
yeah and it would have to be on the in
and we would have to follow the third
example there where we've got the list
of x y y or x y x y
we would have to have an expression that
has a list of atoms and a list of bonds
and we would be rewriting those lists
uh the other expressions uh the the f of
x g of y one
uh we can't represent molecules that way
because those are strictly trees and we
need to represent cyclic
structures i get it so my question here
would be can you give me an example
where we can nest a template a reaction
apply
i just want to see
yeah you do make a dendrimer for example
can you make a dendroma
uh the closest thing we have in this
notebook here is um
taking a a fatty acid and and breaking
each of the three esters in it
one at a time but doing it in a fixed
point operation the saponification
section
right so basically something like less
test list or fixed point we could be
able to iteratively build uh dendrimer
like what you're asking
uh down a little bit further
thinking that we will see some examples
more along those lines in the next
um
let me check my notebook to see where
that went
we do have another meeting with a very
similar set of uh invitees okay i think
we're gonna i mean this this is a
complicated problem that you've
discovered i mean this
this whole thing what is this what is
that is that is that different cases of
different ways those
no those are all the different products
that you can come out using a given set
of reagents a given set of input
molecules and the given template
reaction
because the patterns match
both reactants in different ways
and
in this case here
[Music]
what a beautiful multi-way system story
stay tuned
yeah i mean
in three years you can have all of those
in practice only a few of those will
actually exist due to certain rules
and what's the typical reason they don't
exist
like the the assault is too strained or
the
the electrons do not
interact right so they have to be in
this kind of position relative to each
other
and can we detect that failure or is
that beyond what we can compute about
these molecules
that's actually a good question
if we've got 3d geometry we can do a lot
of it
okay
a bit of a stretch with just the the
topology
yeah
okay okay
the the example i was looking for is
this section called uh
tricoprolal glycerin and i think that
one has been removed from this notebook
okay all right fine
you know the thing that's so crazy about
this field is that that as we were
saying at one time before right if this
was particle physics i could rattle off
all these weird names of you know
saponification and all this kind of
thing but i don't i don't know that for
chemistry unfortunately i i learned it
for something much less useful in
chemistry because
you know particle physics is much less
accessible at least in this century than
than chemistry um but uh it's just uh
i'm sorry that's just an editorial
comment about the fact that each one of
these things is a is a kind of a
personal friend for people who know
chemistry um exactly who else
um
the
and one day i should learn all this
stuff
um
oh i got back by the way we're going to
play around with the emerald cloud lab i
mean i got back a long thing from from
uh brian about that and i oh okay he's
he's proposing
we try and um
uh have you started have you guys looked
at their actual documentation by the way
they now have detailed documentation
online for all their you know i looked
at the one for the hplc
machines and it's a huge long piece of
you know lots of welcome language code
for how you determine you know whatever
they are buffer solutions and who knows
what else that you put in the machine
um
i've seen a preliminary version
many months ago but if they've updated
them they haven't seen that
okay well anyway i'm going to try i mean
my my my syllable project was going to
be to try and measure
uh what are they called flavonoids in
the chocolates
yeah just just as a first step in using
their technology stack i mean clearly
not the most profound thing to try to do
but at least it involves you know
getting some i mean that
the claim is that that should be easy
so
um
stephen could you forward me brian's
reply please oh yeah yeah yeah thank you
um
um
[Music]
we really need another meeting here
because we didn't really make much
progress on this one we will definitely
this is a complicated issue there's a
complicated area a complicated issue i
mean what you you know what you're doing
here
i mean
you know the primary design issue here
is this is how to represent
named pattern variables i think yeah
and a secondary issue is this thing that
i don't fully understand yet which is
are you pulling in two universes is this
a clash of universes or is it something
that happens within a single universe so
to speak and also the one thing that is
a little different okay
between actually this is actually this
is a very interesting point
a big difference between what you're
doing
and
what we've been used to with graph
rewriting is
you know that oxygen has to land up
somewhere there's conservation of atoms
which there is not
in our
um
uh for example in our hypoglossary
writing there is no conservation of
atoms in real chemistry there is
conservation but these rules can be
written without conservation and a lot
of times practicing chemists do that
because you don't care whether a certain
stuff ends up you care about certain
things right you you
don't care about the whole picture
be
there is a caring about it it just may
not be necessary for the
conversation
yes correct
hold on what would happen if one of
those oxygens was missing on the right
hand side what is it what does it mean
so if so the rule basically for this is
if uh if an atom is has a pattern
attached to it if it has a mapping
number then it must appear on both sides
of the equation if it doesn't have one
then you then it can disappear and it's
just it goes off into the solution or
something like that
yeah chemically that's what happens and
oftentimes you know for the
esterification they don't worry about
what happens to that water molecule
uh that you thought you know that you
had said was oh this is another universe
that we just created but you just get
it's just ignored would they they know
it goes off into solvent
right
um unfortunately if you want to pay
attention to the energetics of that
process you can't let it just disappear
yes yes that's right jason you know it's
detailed in case the case it's okay
sometimes you want to pay attention to
the water sometimes
okay
and and
so what an earth would that mean
let's see for us
when we have a pattern transformation
and the pattern variable doesn't appear
on the right hand side that's cool i
mean if we don't care just means it
doesn't that
there's no conservation of matter so to
speak in that case there's no
conservation of expression fragments
which is fine
um but you can't have something where it
appears on the right but didn't appear
on the left
yes
okay so i mean
you can't like pull it out of the
solvent or something you can't
jason you we could do that can't we i
mean we just i mean we attach an atom
number to it right now
and you can
make extra atoms appear
right i mean in general these are
can be used to modify model sorry actual
chemical reactions but a lot of the the
reactions that we find in that i find in
the wild meaning on github and like when
i search for these things uh
reactions written in that string format
they are just concerned with trying to
let's see they
they know a big long complicated
synthesis that involves many steps but
in the end
they can boil it down to some functional
get group gets converted into another
one and there are lots of intermediate
processes but i'm just looking to
generate a list of molecules that that
could be potential candidates and so
that are potentially makable and so
i just write down a
reaction smarts or some reaction
expression template that take goes from
first step one to step 20 and skips
everything in the middle
and uh it
so in that way these can be really
general but that's why we have
we would have things like reaction
balance cue and other things to uh um
to really
verify that you want
the thing to be physical
right
um okay we are we are unfortunately
running out of time here
um
and uh
um
and and
we will um actually there's comments
here from dong's on a live stream
um
oil and gas does reforming to make rings
which upgrades gasoline octane oh i see
that makes sense
for example n-heptane might be
refor reformed into toluene plus extra
hydrogens
um
and polymerization can be expressible as
nested reactions yes i i mean i agree as
you're adding a little piece on to the
end
um all right we have to wrap
unfortunately right now um but we will
be continuing and um
uh
um
for folks on the live stream uh bye for
now um
and
uh you